si les stars adorent raconter leur vie
sur les plateaux télé ou dans les livres
il ya pourtant une notion qu'elle
n'aborde presque jamais c'est l'aspect
financier car en france l'argent est à
bout et le show-business ne déroge pas à
cette règle
régulièrement interrogé par les
journalistes sur les sommes qu'elles
gagnent les célébrités bottes souvent en
touche et évite de révéler ses chiffres
au coeur de nombreux fantasmes
le comédien christophe lambert explique
qu'en france le succès et l'argent ne
sont pas bien vus en france
kenji girac quant à lui expliqué ne même
pas parlé d'argent avec son propre
courage je ne parle pas de chiffres avec
mes parents ni avec ma famille ni avec
rien pour lui c'est indécent ça peut
leur faire quelque chose de pas bien
c'est pour ça que je n'en parle pas que
je ne veux pas montrer je pense aux gens
qui se lèvent tous les matins et killian
1200 ou 1300 euros par mois l'acteur
dany boon avait également été embarrassé
après un article qui révélé les sommes
qu'ils gagnaient au cinéma à l'occasion
de la sortie du film radin dans lequel
il incarnait le rôle principal le
comédien était revenu sur son rapport à
l'argent
aujourd'hui ça va mais quand j'ai
commencé j'ai eu du mal à accepter d'en
gagner par rapport à ce que j'ai vu
quand j'étais petit par rapport à mes
parents j'avais honte de gagner de
l'argent
plus récemment c'est l'actrice charlotte
valandrey qui a révélé combien elles
étaient payées dans la série demain nous
appartient sur tf1 j'ai un minimum de
quatre par mois quatre mille îles à peu
près malgré tout la nouvelle génération
de célébrités de téléréalité a beaucoup
moins de mal à parler de ce qu'elles
gagnent sur les réseaux sociaux beaucoup
de ces starlettes affiche sans complexe
leur fortune sans se soucier des
diverses polémiques que cela déclenche
parfois alors selon vous l'argent est il
tabou dans le show business c'est vrai
que voilà il y en a plein qui révèle
leur salaire voilà il ya pierre ménès en
novembre dernier pierre ménès avait
dévoilé son salaire sur non-stop people
visiblement il s'attendait pas à ce que
le montant soit repris
regardez ici réduit il il avait dit
jusqu'à 2000 euros par mois canal+ soit
le même salaire qu'un ministre voilà
yanagi en 2018 capital affirmé que nagui
percevait entre 750 euros 750 mille
euros et un million d'euros par an et
120 milles à 150000 euros de salaire
annuel
chez france inter voilà il dit li a dit
on ne doit pas très loin voilà il donc
il a avoué que c'était voilà ce que ceux
où se situer chez jean marc morandini
samuel etienne avait révélé qu'il était
beaucoup moins payés que julien lepers
pour présenter questions pour un
champion julien lepers gagné autour de
40000 euros par mois et vingt mille
euros apparemment pour samuel etienne à
peu près alors l'argent doit-il être
taboue
dans le showbiz dans le show-business
dites nous ce que vous en pensez et
dites-nous vous aussi ce que vous
envoyez eric naulleau ces deux fois
tabou en france parce que d'abord on est
un pays de tradition catholique et
tradition catholique a un peu de mal
avec l'argent c'est toujours un peu sale
ça et pourquoi ça doit être tabou parce
que il ya 95% des gens qui galèrent et
dès que vous donnez un salaire vous
passez pour un super privilégiés et ça
commence très tôt 1
donc en plus les superstars eux gagnent
des supers somme d'argent et c'est
absolument impossible à en tant que vous
avez beau expliquer qu'ils bossent quand
même que c'est mérité une certaine
manière c'est inaudible pour les gens
parce qu'il galère alors le jour il ya
quelques années mimie mathy avait
déclaré que son cachet pouvaient
atteindre jusqu'à 250 mille euros par
épisode de joséphine ange gardien
une somme qui a baissé depuis gilles
verdez j'entends ce que direct mais je
suis pas du tout d'accord et c'est vrai
que la tradition en france et pas parler
d'argent contrairement aux sociétés
anglo-saxonnes
il ya plusieurs raisons mais moi je
trouve qu'on parle du salaire des
joueurs de foot on parle du salaire des
ministres
ja il doit pas y avoir de tabou il faut
pouvoir donner son salaire ça ne doit
pas être une gêne et les gens qui
gagnent eux vous avez vu que ça gêne
nous l'a fait pour les césar ça fait une
énorme pot limit oui il allait pourquoi
ils donnent les allées les salaires tout
ça alors ça gêne les professionnels de
la profession mais le grand public lui
bah moi c'est énorme et je vous donne
mon opinion je trouve que le grand
public lui il a envie de savoir les
salaires pour moi c'est une transparence
nécessaire voilà soudainement la vie
mathieu alors est-ce qu'il doit tabou et
ce qu'il était bon moi je pense qu'il
doit être tabou parce qu'encore une fois
le fait de donner de l'argent c'est
idiot tu donnais les salaires ça
sous-entend que les salaires c'est une
grille du réussite dans la vie cité hôte
est réussie c'est eh bah t'as pas réussi
par dont la réalisation de soi c'est pas
par l'argent
en revanche ces teams table oui et moi
je préfère des gens qui vont tellement
comme vous comme moi que d'autres disent
voilà combien vous gagnez je vous
répondrai pas parce que ceux qui
répondent soit le goûter vous dites la
vérité c'est un désamour aux immondes on
donne on donne dans cette émission donne
le salaire brut
enfin j'en ai tellement vu qu'ils
mentent et qui annonce trêve en général
la partie serait trop technique qu'il ce
salary de leur société mais comme à dire
derrière qui se prennent six cent mille
sept cent mille 20 millions d'euros de
dividendes à la fin de l'année voilà ça
c'est juste c'est juste à imposer à 30%
donc ils mentent tous donc au moins dit
la vérité et oui pourquoi évidemment
c'est tabou et parce qu'une preuve c'est
qu'on peut pas expliquer derrière ce qui
se passe alors souvent on saura salaire
comme ça tiens je suis chroniqueur je
prends deux mille cinq cents balles
travers et avec me sens fort mal pour
deux heures non pas pour deux heures
c'était la fameuse phrase de foucauld
qui un jour était parti faire un
événement pour un bouquet alors on lui
avait dit il est 12h combien c'est il
avait dit
vingt mille euros et la personne d'yves
à 1000 euros pour 2h non pour vingt ans
de travail on n'a pas le temps
d'expliquer ce qu'il ya derrière et
pourquoi on en est arrivé là
donc tout ça aberrant le meilleur
exemple il est aujourd'hui mais c'est
benjamin castaldi il s'est fait démonter
la tête quand il a montré des belles
voitures et moi le seul exemple que j'ai
par rapport à moi pardon c'est un jour
je n'ai pas un snap dans une voiture et
on a vu juste le petit arrondies qui
montrait que c'était une voiture de
sport et je me suis fait insulter toute
la journée derrière ça veut dire mais
allez vous faire [ __ ] j'ai pas voler
la voiture quand même merde voilà toute
ma vie j'ai rêvé d'avoir autour de ce
sport je les ai eus jeu très content de
l'avoir jetée mitchell pied tout seul et
pardon si vous n'avez pas pu vous
emmerde
non mais voilà c'est ça c'est sa
position géraldine non en fait je suis
d'accord avec et mathieu et avec eric
c'est vrai qu'en france on a un vrai
problème avec l'argent soit c'est
suspect soit soit il ya une bielle l'on
vit effectivement benjamin noval a
beaucoup parlé ici quand on voit une
très belle faut une très belle voiture
ben on la reille en france aux états
unis on se prend en photo devant nisand
wahaha super un jour j'espère que je
pourrai mais a payé effectifs et moi je
pense était le solaire derrière des
chroniqueurs et voilà comme ça va
l'entendre riche en améliorant ce
colloque encore une fois le diktat de la
transparence de tout savoir pour toi
alors à ce moment là on va s'arrêter
belge il alors dit nous à ce moment là
toi combien tu gagnes et 600 euros par
émission je l'étais il a dit la vérité
il est gillard est la trousse et c'est
la vérité c'est la mairie qui va falloir
savoir est ce que tu as une voiture
qu'on mène voiture est ce que tu es
propriétaire est ce que tu t'es mais m
alors oui mais je veux dire c'est que
ces gens si vous presque totalitaire il
ya des gens qui nous l'ont reproché ici
d'abord on dort nous reprocher de donner
les salaires de certaines personnes
puisqu'on est l'émission médias donc
forcément on l'a 2010 à balan puisque
vous l'avez donné sur les autres
pourquoi vous donnez pas pour vous
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
gens-là jean-michel moi je suis je
trouve c'est un peu tabou et pas pour
les mêmes raisons mes camarades mais
parce que je trouve que quand un parti
mais on sait que c'est tabou c'est parce
qu'on a conscience quand même qu'il ya
le fossé entre ceux qui viennent
beaucoup et ceux qui gagnent très peu il
est indécent quelque part mais
franchement moi je prouverai une
certaine gêne je les ai déjà dit mon
salaire et si mes shoes c'est vrai c'est
que ces combats de salaire ni le jour
d'accord il parle car vous l'avez dit
jean michel ouazine l'est déjà puisqu'il
est un des plus anciens c'est un
magnifique salaires trouve ça énorme
maison et non je sais moi j'ai le
souvenir de mon père je me suis inquiété
et qui était chirurgien et quand il ya
jours il avait oublié sa feuille de paie
dans la photocopieuse et signe c'est une
infirmière qui leur a porté son sa
feuille de salaire il m'a dit j'ai eu
honte parce que je gagnais tellement par
rapport aux infirmières que ça m'a mis
une gêne quand il était petit fils de
paysan
il m'a dit j'ai une telle odeur
de salaires entre les deux que ça m'a
gêné voilà bah moi j'ai aussi ça te gêne
un peu voilà donc voilà oui isabelle moi
je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui vient
d'être dit en plus souvent c'est des
salaires qui s'en donnaient des sommes
qui sont bonnes et il ne correspond pas
à la réalité
par exemple quelqu'un qui travaille à la
télévision comme journaliste si les
rédacteurs en chef
s'il dirigera ses des salaires qui
s'accumulent ils se confondent pas sûr
et donc souvent les justes au une partie
effectivement de leur zèle donc ça veut
dire que c'est au contraire son
victimiser à un panier et tout mondiaux
regarde qui touchent comme pognon des
fois ils touchent moi que ce fronton
quoi qui touchent plus d'accord ok
vraiment c'est vrai c'est ce qui est ce
qui a été dit là c'est vrai c'est c'est
tabou déjà l'argent en france et moi je
pense alors c'est que moi qui pense à et
bien sûr je comprends les la vie des
autres je pense que c'est parce que
c'est le show business quand tu entends
120000 euros pour une présentation un
film 4 millions d'euros pour un film les
gens ils n'arrivent pas à comprendre
comment tu peux pour un film ou une
présentation touché le comprennent mieux
pour des joueurs de 15 ans mais ne
comprennent pas non plus bon joueur de
foot tu vas parler avec des gens qui
vont te dire regarde moi de ces connards
juste pour moi les gens comme on rase
moi dans ma vie me disent regarde moi ça
c'est trop payé trois millions parce
qu'ils courent pas pour courir après un
ballon à messi c'est mieux a été cédé je
pense que c'est surtout les gens se
disent ils foutent rien ils font un film
et après ils sont tranquilles toute
l'année c'est pour ça que c'est le
showbiz avec vous at il détaillé vous
ici moi je trouve que je suis très bien
payé je suis dans la période de ma vie
où je gagne le plus d'argent dans tout
dans ma vie voilà j'ai mon salaire de
chauffeurs livre à des pressions de la
vie' puisque gilles l'a dit je vais le
dire j'ai 280 euros ici j'ai la période
de ma vie où je suis content par jour
brut par jour et ces jeux je fais pas de
folie avec gelée déjà dit si je fais de
remboursement de crédits anticipé pour
pouvoir finir de payer un bien voilà
mais je pense que c'est plutôt l'argent
est tabou parce que c'est beaucoup
d'argent par rapport à ce que ça
représente pour les gens les gens ont du
mal à comprendre moi le premier moi le
premier j'ai du mal à aca à faire des
calculs
quand je me dis le mec qui a touché 4
millions 3 millions
mais j'ai pas assez d'une vie pour
toucher trois minutes il a touché en un
film coluche qui disait comédiens ckoi
comédien c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
coluche qui disait bon aulas dit que des
conneries il a dit aussi des trucs bien
les comédiens ckoi comédien s'est tu
fais un film pendant deux mois est à
leurs hôtes ou le restant de l'année
kevin page a réussi tellement c'est
compliqué comme métier crêpes tombe de
facto tu penses tu que réussi maintenant
mon jeu reprenant le cmpp né à l'époque
gagner cent mille euros par mois pour
animer les jt quand sur tf1 et france 2
c'était 15 mais ça n'a été qu'un nul non
c'était sans miro décembre c'était déjà
énorme laurence ferrari 70 absolument
mais encore une fois c'était qui voilà
un homme qui était animé le jt de la
première chaîne d'europe
combien eva green qui gbo et s'il est là
c'est pas par hasard non pas par hasard
sélectionnez réussi mon fidèle culture
générale pas commun mais on s'en foutent
de la terre des rares maisons la plus
intelligente que ton ppda qu'à une
oreillette un premier campagne de com et
peut dire comment ils vont du bas jeune
homme est large et la salle la tulipe
énorme connerie ouais tu dis non c'était
un mec dans la foulée de même ce matin
au soir alors que les gens n'importe
quel sujet mais semblant je vais bouffer
dans cette ville tient pas deux minutes
elle n'a pas aimé matin michel afin que
l'intelligence qui brille taille et
tirez vous des travailleurs un cookie
sur 1000 et 2000 euros par mois il ya
des fois ferait j'en connais qui
galvanise euros sans heurt qu'il faut
pas forcément que cela vendre sa laïcité
qui prennent des risques qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent pas pardon dans tous
les musées il y en avait pas dans le
show mais ce contenu pognon je lui un
sur saône à des problèmes de la france
qui fait que ça reste à bout c'est qu'il
ya des métiers qui est objectivement
sont mal payés aux agriculteurs sur
twitter affirmant je vous semblez le
geste et toi c'est ce que j'ai fait un
truc pas du tout à celle dont il ya de
la frustration tout à fait hrc s'est
passé des changes il sait des vocations
les policiers les pompiers les policiers
légende cents à berkshire légende
nettoyage des eaux qui s'occupe de nos
enfants c'est crevant redressement les
avocats vous écrivez une lettre non non
non non je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
ce que dj là-dessus effectivement c'est
vrai que le vrai souci c'est la raison
pour laquelle effectivement comme le dit
comme l'écrira lé dinh il ya de l'envié
parfois c'est parce que les métiers qui
devrait être très rémunérés et bien
rémunérés ne le sont pas sauf que cette
disparité là elle saute aux yeux est que
les gens juste pour terminer par
ailleurs ce qui me chagrine moi c'est
que toujours lorsqu'on donne des sommes
qui sont parfois importantes
on a le sentiment qu'on l'a volée et on
doit avoir le rouge au front parce qu'on
aurait ces sommes là on a enfin moi je
pense que les gens qui ont ces sommes-là
si les on sait qu'il les mérite et
qu'ils ont travaillé moi je suis assez
pour ça c'est à dire que et en plus je
viens d'une famille est aisé monde mon
père a bossé 7 jours sur 7
il a quitté l'école à 14 ans ma grand
mère était concierge donc je sais d'où
je viens
voilà mes et l'argent que je gagne ou
que les uns et les autres on gagne on
travaille pour la yeah yeah man payant
il ya une enquête
il ya une enquête qui est sorti les
chroniqueurs de tp donc temps entre 150
euros et 1500 euros par émission
valérie benaïm 1200 euros pour
l'émission c'est l'aspect les voilà oui
bon voilà non et benjamin castaldi 4000
euros par prime sur ses buts à voilà
c'est ce qui est sorti dans l' enquête
le journaliste ne révèle pas les
salaires ni d'arthur il dit ni de nagui
ni de cyril hanouna digne de moi car
difficile à établir avec précision à
cause de leur double casquette
d'animateur producteurs et c'est vrai
que c'est souvent voilà compliqué c'est
vrai qu'ils ne sortent pas voilà on va
dire la vérité et voilà il c'est vrai
que moi j'ai moi je n'ai jamais donné
mon salaire
là je vous dis parce que c'est vrai que
je suis gêné voilà le donne et oui et
géraldine mais pas des meilleures villes
et cités locale révèle je le reprendrai
avec moi tu permets pas de démagogie à
l'envers parce que par exemple cyrille
bien cyrille ok il gagne peut-être très
très très très bien sa vie mais crée
aussi des dizaines et des dizaines
d'emplois est en fait ya aussi des
métiers comme ça qu'ils paraissent
utiles qui paraissent dérisoires du
déplacement mais pas juste en face à
hyères les 300 il fait 300 chèque par
mois mais ça ne soit pas d'un comédien
on dit que venise à chaque débat envie
de choquer mais raymond on a besoin d'un
comité de parents inquiets jerry arnett
je te parle pas d'une boîte de est une
boîte d'une société qui a donné ça fait
ça fait vivre intime quand avant
blommaert il va faire arsène lupin ça
fait graver au mexique une énorme et moi
c'est pas génial pour moi non mais les
fans jalouses
mais bon moi j'ai rencontré les en panne
on lui donne un des sous pour cinq ans
pour faire mousser et les gens vont les
attaquer voir en situation mais c'est
tout comme on dit à un truc tout bête là
on parle effectivement des animateurs
mais tu oublies est un truc raymond ya
comme un animateur qui anime une
émission et ugl envie sur la télé
aujourd'hui où il ya 500 ans animateur
en france celui de la 25 qui ont qu'ils
sont comme nous qui ont de l'argent tous
les autres ils sont intermittents du
spectacle et crèvent de faim ils
attendent une chronique et attention les
appels ont fait pas un tour de table
pour cent à pourquoi ces gens crèvent de
faim et sans jus part ça a pesé alors
qu'à vous en génère un retour de lancer
pardon a plongé pour gagner le progrès
pour pour acheter du pain alors donc tu
parles que les gens qui haïssent voulant
pourcentage vraiment le boulanger il se
lève quand vous entendez par tt legends
est ce que vous aimez quand on révèle
les salaires donc la vérité non non non
ce que je trouve que évidemment les mois
je les jeudis et moi moi moi quand est
très indécent annulés en france ma part
témoin moi je suis pas d'accord avec
vous moi je vous dirai la vérité moi je
ne doute pas mais si les révéler mon
salaire je vous dis on connaît le
salaire d'un affirmé on connaît le
salaire d'un boulot redin d'un bon pied
on connaît le salaire d'un policier
on connaît salaire d'un vin d'un
ambulancier en fonctionne rien on ne
connaît un salaire d'agriculteurs on a
une fourchette pourquoi et eux pour
qu'on connaîtrait leur salaire et l'on
connaîtrait pas de repos n'est pas le
salaire jean-michel qu'est ce t'en
penses
oui moi je moi je le dis mon salaire
puisque voilà en tout cas une certaine
transparence mais je comprends que ça
choque
il ya un autre argument je ne le dis
plus parce que personne ne me le
demandait quand je gagnais ma vie
période où on allait bah oui voilà bah
il ya des moments c'était moins maroc
maintenant sentir ça m'intéressait
personnes gilles bosch i pas hypocrite
c'est pour ça que je donne c'est que dès
que je vois sur l'équipe au capital ou
voilà le vrai salaire des footballeurs
le vrai si on regarde tout le vrai
salaire j'achète mais bien sûr je ça
m'intéresse je trouve que ça fait partie
de la vie sociale
c'est pas un critère de réussite mais
c'est pour moi une typologie ça permet
de connaître les gens donc oui ça
m'intéresse kelly questeur bronze tout
ça moi je trouve ça indécent pour les
gens je peux comprendre que les gens ils
le prennent mal et
et peut-être qu'ils sont curieux de le
savoir dans l'après midi ils veulent le
savoir mais après c'est trop indécent
pour les gens on a tous galères et moi
aussi j'ai galéré des années là je suis
hyper heureux ça peut s'arrêter demain
ça peut s'arrêter ce soir j'en profite
tant que c'est là est battu et je trouve
que c'est une honte parce qu'encore une
fois il a fait en sorte qu'on en arrive
là on est aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'ils vont vous aimez quand on donne
les salaires ou pas non j'aime pas parce
que encore une fois tu es les [ __ ] de
riches qui sont qu'ils sont en vie si on
est riche on est forcément manette à
saluer quand on est pauvre on allait on
allait les démagogies de raymond quand
on connaît beaucoup de vous pendant les
gilet jaune
la seule photo où tout où tu parais un
tout petit peu ça m'arrivait 50 façons
tu tentes avaient ferme ta gueule tu es
une belle montre hockey fin du débat ça
que c'était bien gardé des leviers ou
que tu t'es fait chier encore une fois
t'as pas été volé cet argent mat et dans
une banque à monter ta boîte tu as eu
des nuits blanches qui avait pas de
trésorerie tapas et téléspectateurs 6 au
pays